[Music]
hi
everybody thanks for coming for this
talk i've taken some
inspiration from a leonard cohen quote
that
you've probably heard there is a crack
in everything that's how the light gets
in
and so jumping off from that i want to
talk about
the cracks in the foundations of physics
in the foundations of physics we have
theories that are
extremely well confirmed by
observational evidence
but they also have some shortcomings so
we have some puzzles that we know really
really need an answer
and i briefly want to go through what i
think are the most pressing
problems in the foundations of physics
um
that's for starters there's dark matter
which you've probably heard of
so if we look out into the cosmos
and we look at stars in our own galaxy
or other galaxies or galaxy clusters
then we have trouble explaining what we
are
seeing there if we only use the type of
matter
that we have experimentally found
here on earth so um it doesn't really
matter if we are looking at
the velocities of galaxies and galaxy
clusters or the cosmic microwave
background or just the overall
galactic filaments the way that they are
forming
it's just not working out properly in
our theories
and so one of the solutions that
physicists have come up with
is to say well there has to be a new
kind of matter that's out there
in the cosmos which is called dark
matter and though it's not a
particularly great name
uh it would be better to call it
transparent dark matter because it
it's not that it absorbs light it does
not interact with light
at all so that that's a way
to reconcile the observations with our
theories
it's not the only way another way to do
that is
to postulate that actually gravity works
differently
than einstein taught us and that's
called modified gravity
either way there's there's something in
our theories that we are missing
and uh we need a solution to that um
possibly connected to that is the
problem that we don't know what the
quantum properties of space and time are
we do have theories for matter
that is described by quantum mechanics
or more specifically by quantum field
theories
so we know that particles have quantum
properties and they can do
weird things like being in two places at
the same time and they obey
heisenberg's uncertainty principle we
also know
as albert einstein taught us that matter
or more generally all kinds of energy
causes space and time to curve so the
problem is
if you have a piece of metal like a
little particle that has
quantum properties and is kind of
neither really here nor there but
actually in two places at the same time
then what happens with the curvature of
space-time einstein's
theory of general relativity can't tell
us because it doesn't know anything
about quantum properties
so that's a problem it's just
mathematically it's an inconsistency
that requires a solution one of the
ways to resolve this problem is to
quantize
space and time and obtain what what's
normally
called a theory of quantum gravity um
which we don't have yet
um another possibility is that there's
something about
um quantum theories that we don't
understand
so that's the other way uh to
potentially resolve this problem no one
really knows how to do it
and then let me name a third problem
which is that
in in quantum mechanics we don't really
know how measurements work
so quantum mechanics is a theory for for
small things basically
um in principle it also applies to large
things but in in these cases the effects
are so small that we can't observe them
so for
practical purposes it's a theory for
small stuff like single particles maybe
atoms
and the problem is in this theory the
measurement process
is kind of not properly described it's
just there exomatically
in the theory um we use something that's
called a measurement
and then we calculate the probability
for getting a particular outcome
but the theory does not actually explain
what the measurement
is so if quantum mechanics was a theory
for
small particles and your measurement
apparatus is made of these small
particles and the theory should actually
tell you just what a measurement is and
how it works
but it doesn't um so this is another of
the cracks
in the foundations of physics uh before
i go on
i want to tell you a little bit more
precisely what i mean by foundations of
physics
um what i mean with that is a particular
area of physics so physics has a lot of
different
areas that are the areas that i'm
not talking about for example there's um
solid state physics condensed
metaphysics atomic physics nuclear
physics optics quantum optics plasma
physics and so on and so forth
so so that's all parts of physics that
i'm not
talking about i'm talking about those
areas of physics where we deal
with the natural laws that can for all
we presently know
not be derived from any underlying
theory
and that's general relativity which i
already
talked about that's einstein's theory
which
tells us that gravity is really an
effect of the curvature of space and
time
and then on the other side we have the
theory for the matter
in the universe which is quantum
mechanics or quantum field theories
and the particular properties of the
particles
and their interactions that are
collected in what's called
the standard model of particle physics
now what's happening in these areas uh
not a lot
general relativity is more than 100
years old
and the the development of the standard
model was largely completed in the mid
1970s and ever since then
the foundations of physics have remained
unchanged
so we have added some constants to those
theories
for example you may have heard that
20 years ago it was discovered that the
cosmological constant which is a
constant of nature
is not zero as has had been assumed for
a long time but it's actually small and
has a positive
value um the cosmological constant
determines the expansion of the universe
so if it's
um positive it means that the universe
is not only expanding but that this
expansions are actually speeding up um
so we have added this constant to
general relativity um but actually it
was already introduced originally by
einstein so it's it's definitely not a
new thing
um in this in the standard model um we
have
added masses for a particle that's
called the neutrino
but the theory for this um goes back to
the 1950s
there also in the 1970s there were
several of the particles of the standard
model that had not yet been
experimentally confirmed um it's taken
until
um the mid-90s to observe
um all the quarks that are in the
standard model and the final particle in
the standard model
uh was experimentally confirmed in 20
and
12 that's the so-called higgs boson but
also
in this case the theory goes actually
back to the 1960s
so um you know um
we we have not made any progress uh on
these big problems
the cracks on the foundations that i was
talking about um earlier
how have physicists reacted to that well
there's a lot of talk about crisis
crisis crisis in particular if you look
in the media
but if you talk to physicists and uh you
know i would encourage you to
to to do that you know if you run into a
physicist ask them
they will probably um try to tell you
that
there's no such thing as a crisis in the
foundations of physics
and one of the one of the main reason i
think why they would say that
is that if you're yourself working in a
particular area
then it certainly looks like there's a
lot happening because there are always
papers being written
their conference is being held you know
there are seminars
that you go through and you have very
engaging uh conversations and so on
so so if if it's happening right in
front of your nose and it looks like
um there's really um a lot progress
being made
but nothing seems to be coming out of it
um the other the other thing that
emphasis always
tell me um is that i'm just too
impatient you know why
all this talk about stagnation these are
really tough
problems and it just takes some time
to figure out how the universe works and
everyone has their own favorite example
that they name
here for example it took 100 years from
the discovery of atomic spectrolines
to them ultimately being explained due
to quantum mechanics so the discovery
was
around in the 1820s and then
they were explained around the 1920s
or it took 30 years from the hypothesis
of neutrinos so then being
experimentally confirmed
and this is all well and fine but what
these arguments
neglect to take into account is that at
this time there were far
fewer physicists um trying to actually
solve these problems
so today we have many more phrases than
200 or 100 years
ago and the fair comparison would be to
count working hours
so i've i've done a little uh numerical
exercise uh for you
um the number of scientists is
exponentially increasing
um not only in physics but generally in
all disciplines
um actually if you compare physics with
other disciplines of science it turns
out that physics is one of the
slower growing disciplines probably just
because it's
it's fairly old already and
now if you know this factor by which it
is increasing you can calculate it back
and and ask what's the comparison
between the working hours back then
to the working hours um today
um it just just to give you an idea how
much this number
has changed if you look at the data from
the american physical society and the
german physical society
then the number of physicists has
increased by about a factor 100
in the past 100 years and i'm i'm i
don't know
i do not know but i'm guessing that is
probably pretty much the same
in most of the developed world so now
you can guess how much working time
starting today corresponds to 40 years
working time starting
100 years ago okay so um i'll leave you
guys
um five years eight years three years
um it's 14 months
if you go by working hours only
businesses today
should be able to do in 14 months what a
century earlier
took 40 years so i i dare to say
it's it's fair to call it a stagnation
we have known of dark matter and the
lacking quantization of gravity
since about 100 years um this this has
been known
in in the 1930s okay so that's not 100
years but 90 years but it's a long time
and given that the number of physicists
is increasing exponentially
um i i think it's it's not a good
argument
to say that well in the past we had also
faces where not a lot has happened
and in any case the slowdown per se
in and by itself is not what worries me
uh what
merge what worries me is not that
physicists have trouble solving
difficult problems uh because i know how
it is you know
um but my my worry is
that um they have put forward and
continue to put forward
thousands of hypothesis to solve these
cracks on foundations of physics
that all turn out to be wrong
and yet they do not change their
methodology
so i i have good reason to think there's
something really seriously going wrong
and that's what worries me
so exactly what is going wrong well the
problem is
that physicists rely on beauty to try
and make progress in the foundations of
physics
they think that the theories that they
have are not pretty enough
they have certain shortcomings
and the mathematics is not as nice as
they would want it to have
and then they invent prettier theories
and then they are surprised if no
evidence is found that supports
those theories um this image that i have
here
shows the root diagram of e8 e8 is a
particularly big symmetry group that
a lot of people like and then they come
to think that
certainly this pretty mathematics must
have something to do
with the foundations of physics they are
largely unaware that this is what they
are doing
because these requirements of beauty
have become mathematical standards
so physicists are today pretty much
taught that
it's good if a theory which they develop
fulfills certain criteria of beauty for
example it has a lot of symmetry
it has a lot of unified structures
it fulfills the mathematical criterion
that's called naturalness
and so on and so forth and um too many
of them don't reflect
on what they are doing um why is this a
good criterion to even use
um now some philosophers have told me
that i
i should not call this um
ideals of beauty but i should instead
call it
metaphysical requirements um other
people have told me i
should just call it um beliefs
um you know doesn't really matter
what you call it i think all of this is
kind of correct uh the reason that i
call it
um ideals of beauty or appeals to beauty
um is that i think historically that's
where it came from
if you look back into the into the
history of physics
then originally you had this very strong
tie between physicists believing that
the laws of nature are beautiful and
believing
that the laws of nature were made by god
and certainly if god made them they have
to be beautiful
so there was this link there and then
over the course of time
physicists have stopped talking about
god but they still hold on to this idea
that certainly the foundations of
physics have to be beautiful
in a very particular way um so this is
what why i call it
uh appeals to beauty but it's also
correct to just call it
metaphysical requirements so i now want
to tell you
um a little bit in more detail
just exactly what what problems this
causes uh to go
through some um predictions that have
been made
using these ideals of beauty that did
not pan out
starting with a particle that's called
the axion
the standard model contains a number
that's the so-called setup parameter
that
is small physicists think it's ugly
um that that's this criterion of
naturalness that i was
mentioning earlier um there just
shouldn't be any small unexplained
numbers in the theories
um they have therefore tried to make the
standard model prettier and
this prettier theory predicts a new
particle
which is the axiom now this axion was
proposed in the 1970s
and it was pretty much immediately ruled
out it just crudely in conflict with uh
observations and what happened then and
this is this is symptomatic
uh for what would happen later over and
over again um
they did not discard this idea
of there being a new particle um based
on this idea that the standard model has
to be
beautiful in particular way instead what
they did was that they made
their theory of this new particle more
complicated
so that it would evade the experimental
constraints that had been found
to that date so they invented a new
particle which was then called the
invisible axion
and people are still looking for it um
the problem is um well it's invisible
so these particles were specifically
designed to be hard to detect
um and what you see in this image is an
example of one of these experiments
that's
that's looking for these particles uh
there are like one or two dozen of them
none of them have seen any
any accents it's also uh very
interesting sociologically
if you talk to the young people today
they don't they don't call it the
invisible axion they just only call it
the axion if you read it in the popular
news
popular science news um coverage of
axions they usually forget to mention
that actually
the original axiom was already ruled out
in the 1970s
okay so another example of failed
predictions and you've probably heard of
those are the ideas
that the symmetries in the standard
model
should be unified to one large symmetry
group
so what you see in this graphics these
are the particles of the standard model
they kind of
you know there's some structure to it
but it's not as structures as
it could be and a lot of us think that's
that's ugly
um these particles can be grouped
according to three different
symmetries um but these these different
symmetries they kind of
sit a little bit awkwardly next to each
other and you can you can make this much
more beautiful
by postulating that actually the three
different
symmetry groups should be unified to one
big one
so i i should have said earlier but
forgot
that um these three different symmetries
correspond to
three different interactions that we
have in a standard model so that's the
electromagnetic interaction
and the strong and the weak nuclear
force so that there are three forces in
a standard model and they belong to
three
symmetry group so if you combine them it
basically means
there's um actually only one big force
um but to us it appears as if there are
three
different ones and that's certainly an
appealing idea i totally agree on that
the trouble is it does work particularly
good um
[Music]
these ideas generally have the
consequence that protons
become unstable now um protons are one
of the constituent particles of
atomic nuclei there are lots of them
around us
and physicists have looked
for proton decay starting in the in the
1980s
so far they have not seen a single
proton decay
what you can do with that data is you
can set bounds
on the lifetime of the proton we have to
know that if
we we now know that if the proton is
actually unstable it is very very very
long lived
and this puts constraints on these
theories uh some have actually been
ruled out
uh but um physicists have not discarded
those
theories instead they have made them
more complicated and so there's still
people looking uh to find evidence
for um those ideas
um another kind of failed predictions
um the standard model contains another
number that's
the mass of the higgs boson which is
small i should be more precise here and
say it's actually the mass of the higgs
boson divided by another mass
which is called the planck mass so you
get a number that doesn't have units
this number comes out to be about 10 to
the minus 15.
um that's very small and it's supposedly
ugly
now what physicists did and
you've heard this a few times now so you
can probably see what's coming
they have tried to make the theory
prettier to get rid of this small number
one way to do this is to introduce new
particles um so that's the so-called
supersymmetric partner particles
um to each of the known particles in the
standard model there's a partner
particle
um that's supposed to cure this ugliness
in the standard model
these particles were supposed to appear
at the large hadron collider and they
did not
and this is not the only prediction that
physicists have made based on this idea
that
um the standard model has to be pretty
um they have also had this idea that we
should see gravitons at the lhc
or tiny black holes extra dimensions and
so on and so forth
none of that was seen the only new
particle that was seen at
the lhc is the higgs boson
which was predicted already in the 1960s
and the interesting thing about the
higgs boson is that it was not predicted
based on an argument from beauty
so definitely it was not there to make
the standard model uh more beautiful
indeed a lot of people thought that it
was ugly
when it was first um introduced but the
higgs boson has to be there because
otherwise the standard model just
doesn't work that's a very important
point that
i will come back to in a bit okay so
another
fade prediction these are the searches
for dark matter
you've probably heard of them um there's
a particular type of dark matter
particle that's called weakly
interacting massive particle
um this has been sought forth since the
mid
1980s uh so far none of them have been
seen
and each time an experiment comes back
empty-handed
handed um theorists assume that the
interaction probability of those
particles
is just smaller um than what they were
possible
than what they were able to test so you
have to build a larger detector
and this has been going on for decades
what you see in this image
is um one of these dark matter detectors
is called xenon 1t
the 1t stands for 1000 then it's an
upgrade from
the xenon 100 that's an upgrade from the
xenon 10 which is an upgrade from the
original
xenon so each time there's an upgrade
and the sensitivity to the supposed dark
matter
particles becomes better but they still
haven't found it
so why did anyone believe that there has
to be such a particle
well it's a numerical coincidence that
uh it goes under the name the whimp
miracle
if you postulate that such a particle
exists
and it has masses that
are about in the energy range that the
lhc tests
and it interacts with a particular
strength that's about the strength of
the weak interaction um
then um it
it is produced in the early universe in
the right amount
to explain our observations uh for dark
matter
so it's not a particularly strong
argument
at least what i think um but
uh it was enough to convince a lot of
physicists that
it's a good idea to build all these
experiments uh some of them are still
running they still haven't found
anything
um and so another failed prediction this
is the last one
um general relativity has this
cosmological concept which i mentioned
earlier as a free parameter
that's a constant of nature that just
has to be determined by measurement and
that's exactly what was done 20 years
ago
but there are a lot of physicists think
that the value of this concept is not
pretty because it's very small it's not
zero but it's very small
and so what they do is that they invent
prettier theories that
supposedly explain this value of the
cosmos constant
but really the only thing they do is
that they make a very simple theory
more complicated and none of the
predictions from these
theories has ever found any experimental
confirmation so why do physicists
believe in beauty
um ultimately i have to say i don't know
it's a big mystery to me but um
here's what i'm what i'm guessing um i
think they they just don't think
about what they're doing uh largely
they're doing it because um
they've been taught that that's what
you're supposed to do
um there's also you know the in the
popular science literature as well as in
the more professional literature
there's a lot of talk about how
important it is for your theory to be
beautiful and
so on and so forth and when asked many
of them will actually
claim that um that's reasonable to do
because dirac and einstein were
successful because they were guided by
beauty
the problem is that this is just wrong
you know it's it's a false reading
of history derek and einstein certainly
talked a lot about beauty
it was very important to them personally
but after they had their big successes
with uh general relativity and
the drock equation they tried to use
their sense of beauty to construct
more theories and it didn't work for
neither of them it worked and neither
did it work for any other people who've
been going on about
beauty so even for the smartest of the
smart it
it didn't work to rely on beauty and
even and even if it was
right um that there were successful
because they were guided by beauty
then it would then that this would be
cherry picked data you also have to look
at the people who were guided by beauty
but
who actually not successful if you look
at the history of physics then
factors that arguments from beauty have
worked
badly you don't have to dig very deep
to find
ideas in the history of physics that
were beautiful
according to the standards of the time
but that in the end did not pan out
that was exact for example this idea by
kepler that the orbits of the planets
are determined by polyhedra that are
stuck
inside each other um well it
turned out to be wrong um also for a
long time people held on to this idea
that
um all the celestial objects have to
move on circular orbits because they
thought
circles are just the prettiest kind of
emotion that
you can think of there was a peculiar
history
in in the foundations of physics around
the turn of the 90s to the 20th
century in which a group of physicists
became convinced that
atoms are really not in the invisible
ether
so here's an image of such or not it
certainly has a certain
aesthetic appeal i won't deny that it
turns out to be wrong though um and then
um there was this idea that the universe
is eternally unchanging that people try
to
hold on to uh for for a long time so the
universe has always been this way and
will always be this way it's kind of
comforting
i guess uh but it also turns out to be
wrong and then there were
uh quite a variety of um prominent
physicists
who in their late years after they had
made their big success
um try to use their sense of beauty to
come up with
um ideas of unified theories and it just
worked terribly badly yes
people like heisenberg eddington um even
einstein
um they all tried this and it didn't
work
and on the other side we have ugly ideas
that work just fine um
best example i can think of as a fly
trap it's ugly but it works just fine
uh quantum mechanics for example a lot
of physicists think quantum mechanics is
is ugly
uh but it but it's very very successful
in quantum field theory there is a
procedure that's called regularization
that
we need to get rid of infinities that
already derog
complained about and and uh saturn was
ugly and therefore
the quantized version of electrodynamics
would have to be wrong
um well it turned out that the iraq was
wrong and not quantum electrodynamics
um yeah and then the elliptical orbits
and um
the big bang idea that was originally
considered to be repulsive
so relying on beauty is bad science and
we can learn this from
history and seeing that
there just is no correlation between
beauty and
explanatory power it makes it only more
puzzling for me why
why scientists uh insist
that this is something that i should be
drawing on there's also just no reason
to expect that there is
some correlation between beauty and
explanatory power when it comes to the
foundations of physics evolution
certainly did not prepare us
to try to come up with a theory for
quantum gravity say
um it's just stuff that we that we can't
see that we can't experience with our
own senses and there's no reason to
think that
evolution prepared us um
for how it should look like also the
standard
standards of beauty change and there's a
very good book about this by
um the philosopher james mac alistair
who has listed several examples of where
standards of beauty
have changed in the history of science
and i think this is a very good argument
to see why it's a bad idea to
use ideas of beauty to construct
theories it's really putting the
carriage before the horse
it is describing nature that makes the
theory
beautiful not the other way around so
beauty is the end point
of scientific investigation it should
not be the starting point
and i think that this obsession with
beauty is really the reason why
we are seeing um the stagnation in the
foundations of physics
um physics is a very mature discipline
and the simple things have been done so
it takes increasingly more time and
more need to test new theories and this
means we must choose very carefully
which theories we even put to test if we
make a wrong choice if um we come
forward with an unpromising theory
then what happens is that we get
negative experimental results this means
the theory is just uh being ruled out
and that's also a result but it's not a
very useful result
um if you want to develop a new theory
um so the result is that we have a lack
of data
lack of data in the sense that we have
no positive evidence for a new
phenomenon
for which we could construct a theory so
we get stuck with the unpromising theory
um and the cycle just repeats and we
have basically been in this cycle for
the past 40 years
so um this then brings me to my
recommendation uh what
what i think physicists could do better
uh i think we should learn from history
progress in physics has either been
driven by experiments so historically um
there's been a lot of experiment driven
um breakthroughs um where
we had data that was in need of a theory
but progress can also be theory driven
where
you have a prediction that is done being
tested and confirmed
by experiment and if experiments become
harder to do then this theory driven
progress becomes more and more
important so we really have to pay
attention to how to do it
and um if you look at the cases where
theory-driven breakthroughs have
happened
uh it was the resolution of
inconsistencies in the theories
that were then being used in the
foundations of physics that worked
so i have some examples for this here
electromagnetic waves
are necessary
to make electromagnetism internally
consistent
so there were a prediction that was then
experimentally confirmed
einstein's theory of special relativity
resolved an inconsistency
between electrodynamics and
galilean invariants of space and time
general relativity then further
resolves an inconsistency between
special relativity and newtonian gravity
um
anti-particles that was derock's great
breakthrough
it was based on a resolution of the
inconsistency between special relativity
and the first formulations of
quantum mechanics and after some further
work this eventually led to the
development of quantum field theories
which are the theories that we still use
in the standard model today
and also the higgs as i already said is
necessary for
consistency of the standard model
without the higgs the standard model
will
eventually predict uh probabilities
larger than one so that that's just
mathematical nonsense
and so um there are as i and i started
with this in the very beginning there
are real problems and foundations of
physics that
are not um you know
next lack of beauty um
i already mentioned these in the
beginning um dark matter
the lacking theory of quantum gravity
the quantum measurement problem there
are also certain aspects of dark energy
that are actually problems of
inconsistency so i think physicists
should focus
on trying to solve these problems
um so this brings me to my summary using
criteria of beauty to
assess theories is bad scientific
methodology
there is no reason it should work it has
not worked in the past and it does not
currently work physicists should instead
focus on resolving
inconsistencies because that's
how the fight gets in if you like this
and if you want to know more
about the problems in the foundation of
physics i encourage you to
check out my book lost in math which was
recently published as paperbook
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv